ah it's more than hot
this deathly
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we welcome
priyanka chopra jonas to the show
from india to hollywood she's one of the
world's most famous and successful actor
slash producers her latest film the
white tiger is currently streaming on
netflix
ditto for we can be heroes and her
memoir unfinished is set to release on
february 9th
priyanka chopra jonas welcome to the
show thank you so much sean so
terrifying to be here again well you
know
nick has done the show a time before and
then of course you've had a taste of
what's to come during our appearance on
the tonight show
what's going through your mind as you
prepare for this 10-wing gauntlet here
you know i'm usually a big fan of hot
wings um
and i'm a big fan of spice but i've seen
what happened on nick's show
and i remember what happened on mine
so i'm actually terrified this time
she'll be doing it again
crying on national tv international
okay okay this should be doable
hopefully
okay got a little kick
let's do a book
[Music]
so your new film the white tiger tells a
distinctly indian but
universal story about poverty and what
it can do to push a person to break
through these fixed class structures
how would you describe the master
servant relationship like is it just as
simple as rich powerful people taking
advantage of the poor
or is it more complicated than that well
the complexity is something even i can't
claim to understand for sure because
every country every culture has its own
dynamic but the universality of this
story
is the socio-economic difference that
exists all over the world
and that divide is only increasing the
story happens to be based in india but
it definitely is
you know sort of self-reflection
narrative of being able to pull yourself
if you can out of the vortex of you know
that vicious cycle
and this is just like an entertaining
sarcastic um perspective on that
[Music]
hmm that looks good i need one of those
in my house
hey keep it i kind of am yeah you sent
them to me
all the way to london so thank you we
got you we got you
so besides being slapped in the face by
a monkey when you're in boarding school
one of the parts of your memoir that i
found most
fascinating was your first trip to the
united states which i imagine
as a young girl who grew up in india was
a massive culture shock
what were your expectations of america
before your first visit
and how did of all places cedar rapids
iowa stack up
you know i my mom used to watch a lot of
these uh
shows bold in the beautiful remington
steel i'd seen
saved by the bell so to me that was
america
it was you know quaffed hair couture
clothes
you know high school bright and happy
and that was the culture shock for me
high schools
anyway it's scary but then when you're
coming from another country it's even
more scary you also spent some time in
indiana how big a thrill was it for you
to meet
larry bird when the kings played the
pacers in mumbai
i was very excited about it i had
partnered with in nba and nba india
for that first game that happened in
india and then the fact that it was
it was the pacers playing was just so
ironic in fact i think they were really
excited about the fact that i went to
high school in indiana
it was such a like what
good stuff so far enjoy it while you can
i know i know how this game goes sean
so you're coming to us right now from
london but i know that you've spent more
than your fair share of time in new york
city
between those two cities london and new
york which one does
indian food the best you know there's
such a large diaspora
of indian people in in london
and in new york um that if you go to a
right place
then you know you can get really
authentic indian food but i've had some
amazing indian food in london
like really really great for people who
are stuck in a holding pattern of just
ordering chicken tikka masala or
vindaloo every time they go to the curry
house
is there a widely available dish or two
that you'd recommend for people trying
to break out of that
i would recommend biryani it's really
great it's like
um rice with you can have it with meat
you can have it with chicken you can
have it as vegetarian but it's like lots
of little things mixed in it
you should try dosa that's from the
south of india
north of india you should definitely try
the kebabs and the chaat that's great
for the uninitiated how do you explain
achar okay great so achar is basically
pickle but pickled with spices so you
can make a char out of anything
my favorites are garlic chili mango
lime you can make it out of anything and
it's amazing and
it's like a condiment that goes with all
food
hellfire that sounds scary okay
[Music]
i felt that my tongue
[Music]
first little like kick yep
we're on that we're on that path now
[Laughter]
i can see love of the written word seems
to be a theme throughout your life
you've written
song lyrics poetry penned columns for
the new york times then of course you
just finished your memoir unfinished
have you gotten into collecting like
first edition books or anything like
that
you know i've just about built my
library but yes i do
have a first edition of les mis that was
just
gifted to us this christmas and a first
edition of black beauty which was one of
my favorite books as a child
what impact did the master of deduction
sherlock holmes himself
have on you as a literary influence
the cleverness about the that writing
really was
um his character watson's character and
their camaraderie together
plus you throw in the element of you
know him not being a people's person
and um you know the thrill of a case
every time and it's just such a great
great
idea and the writing is always amazing
my nose is sweating but besides that
we're all right
that was really good too digging it so
far so good
all right priyanka chopra we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham where we do a deep
dive on our guests instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so i'll show you the picture
you just tell us the bigger story and
then first things first
we have a hot sauce buffet on the set of
quantico
how did your love affair with hot sauce
begin and do you have any go-to labels
well my love affair with hot sauce began
when i started traveling abroad
abroad means outside of india at that
time um
and western food was just not spicy
enough for me
you know my palate was used to having
being raised in india
an explosion of flavors all day you know
from breakfast lunch to dinner
started with tabasco it was very basic
because we used to always have it in my
house my dad loved bloody mary's on
sunday
and then every country i go to i find a
new hot sauce or their
favorite hot sauce my hot sauce
collection is great caterers and that's
what you saw
catering on most of my sets know that so
they always provide and show off
actually
who's got the best hot sauces it's
really cool
how big of a hero were you to your mom
to be able to introduce her to the hoff
she was so excited he gave her a t-shirt
which says don't hassle the hof and she
still wears it
very she's very proud of it she was so
excited and
had quite the moment i felt very proud
[Music]
oh ghost pepper we're getting real now
ghost pepper is fire
[Music]
and it kicks you afterwards
it doesn't happen immediately you know
you know a lot of hot sauce novices they
come on this show they take a bite and
they're like
i'm good and then they don't know that
it has that see like now
like now you're gonna start feeling it
literally
it literally takes especially with ghost
pepper
and few others um it takes like
a good like seven to ten seconds and
then you'll suddenly feel your
tongue on fire it's crazy it was really
good this sauce
and this show gets a little cumulative
as you keep going
so some people watching this may be
surprised to learn that the indian film
industry is the largest movie market in
the world producing films at
two to three times the rate of hollywood
and then with these streaming services a
lot of these titles become widely
available i for example
i watched fashion last night on netflix
oh
have you given any thought to how these
streaming services are breaking the
borders of content to create these
global hits and if so
what insight do you have on how that
whole movement might impact filmmaking
going forward
oh my gosh give it a thought i could
write a thesis on it i've been thinking
about it since it first started and
um i think it's genius the white tiger
for example
would not have this kind of a budget or
this kind of a scale
six years ago it's going to be in 160
countries you can watch it everywhere
but with theatrical that would have been
limited especially a movie with
an all indian star cast iranian director
shot in india written by an indian
author you know
it would have been called independent or
but look at the widespread release it's
got so it's giving
diversity and a chance and i think it's
the natural evolution of entertainment
there's an amazing comfort in being able
to sit on your couch with your family
in your blanket and watch the newest
movie i think
that's going to create opportunity for
filmmakers for variety of ethnicities
for
people from different countries to be a
part of global entertainment
for global entertainment to actually
look like global entertainment
which is you know people from all over
the world and
art from all over the world and i think
this is a great time
okay i'm scared already
[Music]
the honey house but at first
yeah oh yeah
so there's a lot of this so often
well i i don't i don't know what i would
do otherwise that's the thing i just
ended up in this seat
the thing took off and now i think i'm
just tethered here
you know like it's this is the cross
that i bear oh my
oh all right i wish you luck my friend
thank you priyanka i appreciate it so
there's a large portion of the internet
devoted to celebrating your red carpet
sartorial stylings an eclectic array of
working with
indian designers as well as
international labels like ralph lauren
and dior
it's been a massive year for athleisure
during quarantine
was that white dress with the hood that
you wore to armani 2017
an announcement of athleisure's arrival
to the runway
i wish i wish anyone could have
predicted what was going to happen and
how much we were going to take to
athleisure i
certainly have i mean today i happen to
be wearing a dress in your honor but
usually i'm
always in my um in my sweats ah that
just kicked in
yep which fashion record are you most
proud of
wearing the world's largest trench coat
at met gala
or having a wedding veil with a 75-foot
trail that required a 25-person train
it was suggested to me by andrea at the
ralph lauren atelier that you know you
should do a large
train because it was such a large space
that i had to walk i was like all right
if we're gonna do a large one it has to
be the largest
in the world which is why it was so big
but it wasn't the largest in the world
the largest in the world was a woman
some 15 football fields long just
recently
so i gave up on that fight what's the
most ridiculous piece of clothing that
you've ever purchased for your instagram
famous dog diana
um her first montclair jacket
was definitely an obnoxious purchase
all right priyanka you're ready to move
on here to the eighth
one this is the bomb beyond insanity and
fair warning this is probably the worst
of the bunch
it looks like it especially the bottle
it looks like poison
[Music]
beyond insanity [ __ ] okay
i know i know
[Laughter]
i know but if it's any if it's any
consolation you have done this before
you have eaten this sauce before
i think i may have put too much on it it
looks like it
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh
go
[Music]
sometimes you just have to laugh
sometimes you just have to laugh
oh my gosh i know i know
so we've had many seasoned travelers on
this show but i think you take the cake
i heard like prior to last year you were
doing the la to mumbai round trip
every two weeks do you have a jet lag
hack that actually works
yes the jet lag hack that actually works
is
when you get onto a long flight sleep
according to the time of the country
that you're going to land into
[Music]
and that's all i can say but that really
works
i get the sense that you're a big beach
person if you had to pick one of the
places that you visited
which has the most majestic coastline
maldives fiji
uh mauritius turks and caicos
i love the beach oh dying
that was crazy
well if you think that's crazy
we have two more to go
okay i'm indian i'm built for this can
we turn on the air conditioning or open
a window
please yeah there's that one
ah die okay
let's do it sean let's do it let's do it
[Music]
so priyanka you've touched so many
different projects which have reached
audiences
all over the world what's the project or
the thing that secretly makes you
happiest when
fans mention it to you in the wild
sorry was the question
[Music]
um this movie called barfi i did makes
me really happy when fans really like it
because i didn't expect
but also i didn't win any of the awards
that year or i wasn't like
i didn't get a lot of love from
i got love from the fans so that was one
of those you know
movies which really made me feel really
happy about
all right priyanka chopra this is the
last dab of apollo
last wing last question we were almost
at the finish line
god damn it okay
just needed to get it out yep ah
oh my god okay what's this called hollow
apollo i'm saying
somebody get that damn phone
i can't
the walls are closing in i know how it
goes here at the end yeah yeah
oh my gosh my temperature i really want
to check my temperature
i got it last one are you doing it
i'm right here with you cheers priyanka
right priyanka chopra
here we are at the end of our second go
round with the wings of death i'll be at
this time on a slightly less successful
talk show but nonetheless we're going
out with a bang
you know i know that you broke onto the
scene at 17 years old when you were
named
miss world india and then you won miss
world the following year
and my favorite my favorite quality of
beauty queens is that they're able to
answer
any question with confidence even though
if it's impossible for them to be an
expert on it
so with that sorry
my question to you is this what in your
opinion
is the essence of hot sauce and do you
find it to be a force of good
or a force of evil i think the essence
of hot sauce
is the people who made it
and i think the people who made it this
is a testament
to who you really are if you want to
spread goodness
we want to spread evil in the world
i should be crowned for that put the
crown
on her head priyanka chopra jonas the
queen
of hot ones miss hot ones 20 21
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you priyanka
chopra
this camera that camera probably just
the one you're looking at
let the people know what you have going
on in your life i have a movie
that's out on netflix called the white
tiger you must check it out
another one called we can be heroes
which you haven't checked
checked out you should and my memoir
just called
unfinished even though right now i feel
like i am finished
you should check that out too and if i'm
alive
i may see you back on the show sean
great job briana
bye bye everyone
[Music]
thank you so much bye dominique i'm
gonna go find my breath
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in to say thank
you so much for watching today's episode
if you enjoyed it maybe like it maybe
you maybe
throw us a subscribe even if you're
feeling generous and as long as you
keep watching [ __ ] it i'll keep eating